[Musique]
je venais d'avoir 18 ans c'était ma
deuxième année au cégep de jonquière en
arts et lettres puis avait là la fièvre
référendaire qui battait son plein
en octobre 1995 la ferveur pour le oui
était à son comble ici là je pense
qu'elle finance
mathieu gravel se rappelle d'une soirée
à l'amphithéâtre dessus au collège où
les orateurs jacques parizeau et lucien
bouchard avait électrisé la foule comme
inspecteur c'est ce qu'on connaissait
c'est ce qu'on connaît c'est ce que
satan des toits mais est-ce que ça tente
d'être de valoriser ton être ta ta ta
culture ta nation ta langue et job c'est
comme la tarte aux pommes
qu'est ce qui nous ferait dire non à ça
écoutez le québec et pc au bout de la
ligne
on met un x sur un choix pour la nation
peut dire de moi où j'ai participation
moi je me voyais cette amende à voir je
vends citoyens bonjour monsieur mangera
avec monsieur lévesque
j'ai vécu la nuit des longs couteaux
marc andré bédard militants
indépendantistes de la première heure
s'est toujours senti porté par le
sentiment de fierté et de confiance qui
domine au saguenay dans la région nous
avons des entreprises qui des gens
connecte avec le reste du monde plus
difficile peut-être de nous faire des
pins la peur d avance que les personnes
âgées pourraient pas manger nous ici sa
propre anja paerson qui doutaient que
tout le monde allait manger ces trois
par jour pareil le jeune stéphane bédard
était lui aussi impliqué à fond dans la
campagne de 1995
réussir la souveraineté comme les
peuples normaux peuvent le faire il se
rappelle d'une soirée où son père avait
soulevé la foule aux côtés d'un des
leaders de la campagne lucien bouchard
moi ce que je souhaite avant tout c'est
moins québec debout les ans s'est élevé
deux coups et das aboutissent à des prix
tellement que monsieur bouchard qui
avait pris la parole avait dit sa
voiture de parler après marc andré la
fin de campagne avait été très belle
prose m'attendais a effectivement une
victoire en route voudrait 52 et 54 pour
un cinglé on s'attendait à tout sauf ça
ce qui explique que la victoire du nord
par une si faible marge et eu un impact
plus grand ici qu'ailleurs au québec
testée à l'image que tinqueux quand on
perd là je veux dire le une cicatrice
sur leurs terres ça a eu un petit effet
de démobilisation parce que c'est dur
pour des gens qui ont voté à 70 % de
voir le résultat
il ya eu comme un oui à une frustration
qui a atteint leurs militants
c'est à dire non s'est jamais fois sur
toute l'année
je pense qu'on est aussi jeune que ça
c'est plein mais frustrant aussi quand
on y croit quand il met tout notre temps
notre énergie
vingt-cinq ans après le référendum on ne
peut plus parler de ferveur
souverainiste au québec loin de là
l'appui à cette option se situe à 34 %
et l'enjeu de la souveraineté arrive au
neuvième rang des priorités des
électeurs québécois après la santé
l'éducation l'environnement est juste
derrière l'état des routes
tout le monde parlait souveraineté tout
le monde avait un positionnement face à
la question nationale
aujourd'hui on sent que c'est moins coq
un quart de siècle plus tard la planète
a changé et les jeunes aussi
le cégep de jonquière les membres du
club politique ont la tête ailleurs des
amérindiens ils sont fait carrément volé
leurs terres et cuzon qui rennes 3-1
voltige constat plus que nous parce que
justement je pense qu'on est quand même
une bonne réaction présentement avec le
canada et les des bugs sont beaucoup
plus actuelle comme justement gnl québec
par exemple pour l'égalité des sexes
comme on avait dix à l'environnement
leurs assises donc je pense que c'est
une période où est-ce qu'on on veut
révolutionner c'est un sujet dont je
parle mais seulement parce que je
fréquente une école qui se situent en
région les jeunes d'ici se sentent
toutefois interpellé par la notion
d'identité et d'appartenance à leur
société
pour moi une identité québécoise se doit
d'être pluriethnique ouverte aux autres
dans les cours d'histoire c'est très
bref je pense qu'on a pensé comme une
semaine ou deux et a parlé des
référendums qui parlait la révolution
tank et puis je pense que ça serait
bénéfique qu'on en voyait plus
mais c'était plus l'élément de jean
pierre qui est de taille n'est pas perdu
pour mathieu gravel le passage du tort
et le changement des mentalités rendent
le projet de souveraineté plus
improbable aujourd'hui dans notre
quotidien dans notre société on est de
plus en plus individualiste et s'apprend
si je me ramène en 95 on veut participer
à un projet plus grand que nous on parle
d'un projet collectif du projet d'une
nation c'est faux santé faut faire
sentir qu'on fait partie de quelque
chose
les bédard père et fils demeure
convaincu que la souveraineté du québec
est encore possible avec ou sans le
parti québécois ce qui manque selon eux
c'est un contexte approprié pour
rallumer la flamme chez les jeunes on
est un peuple qui a une identité qui
n'est pas la même unité que l'autre
peuple dans la manière de se développer
piétons et ça ça fait changement un
moment donné vous allez avoir un autre
affrontement qui va obliger les gens à
prendre en apprendre aux gens ce qui
reste c'est urgent ou l'importance de 20
alors ça reste à administrer certains
jeunes du saguenay que nous avons
rencontrés disent que l'idée de la
souveraineté du québec n'est pas
incompatible non plus avec leurs
préoccupations sociales si on lit pour m
et télé québec indépendant avant de
prendre soin d'une planète je pense que
ce sera un non pour moi mais si c'est
dans le plan le oui pour hacker les
conservateurs c'est sûr que non mais
pour un québec se soit démocrate qui
veut qui met vraiment l'enfant se bat on
va développer nos forces au québec mais
je serai plus tenté vers le oui à ce
moment le mais je veux pas trop me
prononcer non plus si on voulait refaire
la débauche france face à sas faudra que
ça se fasse au delà de la partisanerie
politique et que ça se fasse un peu de
façon plus citoyenne et que les partis
politiques prennent position sur leur
aujourd'hui sur ce que les citoyens
proposent
aujourd'hui père de famille mathieu se
dit plus raisonnable ne sent pas
l'urgence de relancer le débat sur la
souveraineté ne sait pas non plus s'il
voterait oui ou non un éventuel
référendum sur cette question
la profondeur de la réflexion serait
multi multi balié multiniveaux il y
avait plusieurs ça serait plus purement
émotif comme ça tout ça pouvait l'être
le 25 ans
[Musique]
les ténors du parti québécois ont
longtemps affirmé que la souveraineté
était inéluctable puisque les jeunes y
étaient majoritairement favorables
on constate aujourd'hui que les
partisans inébranlable de cette option
semble au contraire de plus en plus
âgées même au saguenay
[Musique]